this video was made possible by tab for
a cause raise money for charity just by
opening tabs which we were going to do
anyway link in the description it sounds
like the synopsis for an episode of Law
& Order SVU a billionaire financier is
arrested for human trafficking in New
York after the FBI uncovers evidence
that he lured underage girls to his
house where they were molested assaulted
and worse by the billionaire and his
famous pals the public is shocked that
the billionaire was investigated for the
same conduct 15 years ago and got away
with everything
the billionaire happens to have a little
black book containing the contact
information for those powerful people in
America including former and current
presidents this is not in fact an
episode of SVU this is real life let's
look into the multiple prosecutions of
Jeffrey Epstein
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and today we are gonna talk
about Jeffrey Epstein who is under
indictment again for potential sex
trafficking Jeffrey Epstein is a
billionaire financier who is friends and
associates with several rich and
powerful people including President
Donald Trump who once called Epstein a
quote terrific guy who likes beautiful
women as much as I do and many of them
are on the younger side Epstein has been
investigated repeatedly for trafficking
in children who were then forced to have
sex with Epstein and his famous friends
there is evidence that the President may
have known about or have seen red flags
associated with Epstein and that
president Trump's now former labor
secretary helped cover up some of these
crimes now before I go too much further
a quick disclaimer about indictments
versus convictions it is far too easy to
assume that someone who is indicted of a
crime is guilty of the underlying
offense too often that is not the case
and everyone in America is entitled to a
fair hearing so we should look at facts
as they are disclosed to the public with
a grain of salt and with skepticism here
there is both a pending indictment as
well as a plea deal that covered at
least some of this alleged conduct so
there's less of a potential issue in
this particular case because some of the
facts have been admitted to but it's
still important to recognize that people
who have been indicted are not guilty
until proven beyond a reasonable doubt
in a court of law so with that
understanding let's first define what we
mean by human sex trafficking the
justice for victims of trafficking Act
of 2015 or jbt a defines sex trafficking
as recruiting harboring transporting
providing obtaining patronizing or
soliciting of an individual through the
means of force fraud or coercion for the
purpose of commercial sex however it is
not necessary to demonstrate force fraud
or coercion in sex trafficking cases
involving children under the age of 18
the term commercial sex act is defined
as any sex act on account of which
anything of value is given or received
by any person it is illegal to have sex
with someone who is underage I probably
don't need to explain that but in this
day and age is better to be safe than
sorry so keep that in mind when you hear
some of
defenses that refer to allegations of
consent children cannot consent to the
acts that Epstein has allegedly
committed so the allegations and
admissions relevant here are broken up
into two phases the first is in the
early 2000s in 2005 a fourteen-year-old
girl and her parents told Palm Beach
Florida police detectives that Jeffrey
Epstein had paid her and a classmate for
sex the Palm Beach Police Department
started investigating Epstein for
soliciting underage girls for
prostitution they alleged that Epstein's
two assistants Haley Robson and Sarah
kelan would recruit teenage girls to
give Epstein massages in the bedroom of
his Palm Beach mansion once inside the
house Epstein would order the girls to
strip naked and he would assault them
during and after the massage the Palm
Beach police did trash poles where they
went through his garbage and found trash
with the girls names and cell phone
numbers on it Epstein's assistant
actually telephoned one of the victims
while she was talking to police as the
police investigation continued more
victims were identified the police
promptly issued a probable cause
affidavit which normally is all that's
needed to arrest a person in Florida but
in a highly unusual move the District
Attorney's Office referred the charges
to a grand jury instead the local
prosecutors only presented evidence that
Epstein assaulted one of the girls and
they failed to ask the jury to indict
Epstein for having sex with a minor
instead Epstein was indicted for
solicitation of prostitution which is a
much less serious charge
Epstein's legal team swooped in to
negotiate a plea deal that would have
allowed Epstein to enter into a
pre-trial diversion program and serve no
jail time in other words the local
prosecutors were being pressured to just
give Epstein a slap on the wrist the
Palm Beach Police were not happy with
this negotiation and they referred the
case to the FBI
which opened a case file on Epstein for
activities with underage victims in
Florida New York and New Mexico a 53
page federal indictment was prepared but
not filed with the Florida district
court at the same time Epstein's lawyers
were negotiating a plea deal with the US
attorney in Miami
Alex Acosta who later became president
Trump's labor secretary at the time
Epstein's lawyers included Alan
Dershowitz and Ken Starr among other
legal stalwarts Dershowitz is most
famous for defending OJ Simpson while
Starr was the independent prosecutor who
investigated Bill Clinton for having
fair with monica lewinsky later star
became president and Chancellor at
Baylor University allegedly during the
negotiation star was working overtime
for Epstein star told Alex Acosta again
the US Attorney for Miami at the time
that his client would not agree to being
classified as a sex offender which is
normally mandatory for anyone convicted
of a sex offense star also objected to
an addendum to the agreement that said
that the victims would be able to sue
for compensation Starr worked his
connections in the Department of Justice
to request a review of the agreement the
review went on for more than a year and
during this time the FBI continued to
investigate starting up more victims and
more evidence against Epstein the FBI's
new allegations included information
showing that Epstein preyed on Runaways
as young as 13 years old paying them for
nude massages that led to sex the
investigation apparently revealed how
Epstein preyed on poor children using
his assistance to find vulnerable teen
girls who they then paid to recruit
other teens of course minors cannot
legally consent to sex all in all
investigators turned up at least 80
underage victims importantly prosecutors
also found that some of the girls were
given worked with a Manhattan modeling
agency while they were also living in an
apartment owned by Epstein while a new
indictment was prepared prosecutors
reported that Epstein's lawyers had been
harassing the victims however Acosta was
firmly in charge of the negotiations and
agreed to give Epstein what can only be
called the plea deal of a century so
let's talk about this non-prosecution
agreement
Epstein pleaded guilty to a single count
of solicitation of prostitution and a
single count of prostitution with a
minor under the age of 18 the court
sentenced him to 18 months in jail and
adjudicated him as a convicted sex
offender the agreement granted Epstein
and incredibly his unindicted
co-conspirators immunity from federal
charges this is unbelievably unusual you
don't give pleas to people that you
haven't named in an indictment the
federal non-prosecution agreement was
also marked by other things that were
highly irregular and borderline
unethical for example Epstein somehow
managed to remove his computers from his
main residence before the FBI was able
to search the house secondly although
subpoenas were prepared for the computer
records law enforcement never required
Epstein to comply with any of the
penis finally although the plea
negotiations typically includes several
Department of Justice lawyers allegedly
a costume met with Epstein's lawyers
one-on-one without any backup from the
DOJ the end result was a highly unusual
some would say disastrous
non-prosecution agreement that would
only be made public more than ten years
later in exchange for Epstein's guilty
pleas to florida's criminal solicitation
charges the Department of Justice agreed
not to pursue criminal charges against
Epstein for all of the other allegations
Acosta used his authority to lead
prosecutors to drop all other
investigations into Epstein's conduct
further it appears that a cost I agreed
to hide the agreement from the victims
and other witnesses in this case he
granted Epstein's unindicted
co-conspirators and employees blanket
immunity from prosecution some of these
people were named and some were
completely anonymous Acosta also
cancelled the subpoenas which is highly
problematic from the time the FBI
started investigating to the time that
the agreement was struck the victims
were never notified about a potential
non-prosecution agreement nor were they
ever told that it was a possibility in
possibly the most unbelievable fact of
this entire case is that after the
agreement was signed the government
lawyers led by a Kostas started
negotiating on whether the government
would even comply with the crime victims
right act or CVRA the purpose of the
CVRA is to keep victims in the loop
about the investigation prosecution of
criminal defendants certain victims have
a right to know what's going on with a
federal prosecution and it appears that
both the DOJ lawyers and Epstein's
lawyers knew that there was a compliance
requirement however one of Epstein's
lawyers wrote an e-mail directing Acosta
not to have anyone from his office reach
out to the victims in any way after this
email Acosta then went out for breakfast
with the Epstein lawyer where he
promised that the government would not
in fact contact the victims the
agreement also gave Epstein
unprecedented control over whether the
victims could sue him in civil court the
agreement stipulated that Epstein's
attorneys would be permitted to select
the civil lawyers for each victim and an
Epstein would pay those lawyers and that
he would not contest fly ability the
whole purpose of these agreements was to
prevent any of the information from
becoming public Acosta also allowed
Epstein to stipulate that paying off the
victims was not an admission of guilt
whatsoever a cost to also agree that if
anyone requested public
under the state or federal Freedom of
Information acts the government would
notify Epstein before making the
required disclosures thus the deal made
sure that Epstein's lawyers were always
completely informed of what was going on
while the victims were completely in the
dark
Epstein wasn't put in jail in the
traditional sense he spent his nights in
a Florida jail but during the day he was
on work release where his private driver
picked him up each day and drove him to
his office downtown where Epstein was
able to visit with friends and
colleagues for 12 hours a day
meanwhile the victims were waging a
legal battle to have the plea agreement
unsealed Epstein was released from jail
five months early in 2009 although
Epstein's probation prohibited him from
travel the Miami Herald reports that
Epstein regularly traveled between
Florida Manhattan and the US Virgin
Islands I probably don't need to tell
you that this is highly irregular if any
other criminal defendant had done this
they would have been sentenced for a
probation violation
but Epstein continued life unscathed
even hanging out around the beach in
Florida when he was supposed to be at
the office Epstein's probation officer
said it was fine for Epstein to walk
around the beach when he was supposed to
be at work he was allowed to get some
exercise according to the probation
officer additionally Epstein failed to
register as a sex offender as required
by the plea deal which again if any
other criminal defendant had done that
they would have been subject to a
probation violation by late 2009 dozens
of victims had filed civil lawsuits
against Epstein meanwhile Epstein Zechs
Butler Alfredo Rodriguez had possession
of Epstein's little black book of
important people and tried to sell it to
enrich himself Rodriguez was charged
with obstruction of justice for not
giving the black book to police he
served federal prison time and died in
2015 now convicted sex offenders are
required to register in any jurisdiction
where they live enter a Manhattan
district attorney's science you may have
heard of sy Vance for his questionable
handling of high-profile sexual assault
cases including allegations against
Harvey Weinstein but in 2010 a
prosecutor from Vance's office appeared
in new york state court to argue that
Epstein's sex offender classification
should be reduced to a lower level so
that he would have more freedom i've
never heard of this happening before
prosecutors are not in the habit of
telling judges to help sex offenders get
or classification to crimes that they
have already admitted to committing just
listen to what the judge had to say
quote I have never seen the Prosecutor's
Office do anything like this I have done
many cases much less troubling than this
one where prosecutors would never make a
downward argument like this
Vance's office claims that one
prosecutor made a rookie mistake and
that he didn't even know that Epstein
was appearing in your court to argue
about his sex offender classification
but that probably doesn't make a whole
lot of sense by this point in 2010
Epstein was a billionaire whose
escapades had received considerable
press attention Epstein tried to
rehabilitate his image in 2011 and 2012
by donating large sums of money and
waging a PR campaign however in 2012 a
woman named Virginia Roberts alleged
that she was forced to have sex with
lawyer
Alan Dershowitz and Prince Andrew
although victims and alleged victims
continued to file civil lawsuits and
fight for the Florida indictment to be
unsealed in 2016 Donald Trump was
elected president his connections to
Epstein made mild headlines in June of
2016 when a woman going by the name of
Katie Johnson said that the President
had raped her at a party at Epstein's
mansion in 1994 when she was 13 years
old at the time Trump and Epstein deny
those allegations and the lawsuit never
went anywhere because eleven days before
the election in 2016 Johnson dropped her
lawsuit alleging that she had been
threatened around the same time shortly
after the inauguration President Trump
nominated Alex Acosta to lead the
Department of Labor
although lawmakers briefly questioned
Acosta about the epstein affair Acosta
was confirmed flash-forward to today in
2019 victims finally won an important
court battle the 2006 florida indictment
was unsealed revealing publicly for the
first time how deeply involved in human
trafficking epstein appeared to be
victims also won their lawsuit alleging
that a Kostas office had violated the
Crime Victims Rights Act by failing to
notify them under the CVR a victims have
a right to be reasonably protected from
their assailants to be notified of any
public court hearings in a timely
fashion to be informed in a timely
manner of any plea bargain or deferred
prosecution agreement and to speak at
any court hearing involving a plea deal
or sentencing several victims sued in
Court alleging that a cost and a DOJ had
failed to follow this law by keeping
them in the dark about how the case with
Epstein had progressed now under the CVR
a a victim may make a motion to reopen a
plea or sentence only if the victim has
asserted the right to be heard before or
during the proceeding at issue and such
right was denied the victim petitions
the court of appeals for writ of
mandamus within 14 days and in a case of
a plea the accused has not pled to the
highest offense charged the federal
district court judge ruled the
prosecutors had violated the CVRA by not
letting the more than 30 identified
victims know of the deal so that they
could have a chance to oppose it the
judge ruled that the government gave
deliberately misleading information to
victims and promised Epstein's lawyers
not to notify the victims of the plea
deal the judge ruled that the government
led the victims to believe that the
investigation and prosecution was
ongoing when in fact the agreement had
been signed and Epstein had already been
sentenced however the judge did not
reopen the plea deal instead he gave the
Department of Justice 15 days to come up
with a settlement proposal
the DOJ argued that there was nothing
wrong with how Acosta handled the case
it's against this legal backdrop that
prosecutors in New York are taking aim
at Epstein once again the US Attorney's
Office for the Southern District of New
York charged Epstein recently with child
sex trafficking in violation of 18 USC
1591 which outlaws sex trafficking
activities that affect interstate or
foreign commerce the new indictment
refers back to the allegations in
Florida New York and New Mexico that
were the subject of the earlier
agreement now although those events
happened between 2002 and 2006 there was
no longer statute of limitations for
child trafficking cases the statute of
limitations was originally five years
but before Epstein statute of
limitations had run lawmakers changed
the rule so that there was no longer a
statute of limitations for these
particular cases which means that
Epstein will not be protected by any
effective statute of limitations
now whether Epstein's original plea deal
will protect him and give him immunity
is a bit of an open question normal
practice is to include a clause saying
it only binds the local US Attorney's
Office which signed the agreement not
any of the other US Attorneys offices
which may seek to
press charges but the plea agreement
drafted by Acosta does not include this
clause this is of course incredibly
unusual and highly irregular
although Epstein's lawyers will surely
try to argue from this broad language
that the entire federal justice system
cannot prosecute Epstein for the conduct
occurring in Florida in the early 2000s
there's other language in the plea
agreement which more specifically says
the prosecution cannot take place in a
specific federal district if this
particular plea agreement is litigated
it's very likely that a judge would find
in favor of the Department of Justice
and find that this plea agreement does
not bind every other u.s. district
Epstein's alleged crimes took place in
New York as well as Florida so federal
prosecutors in the New York district
probably have the right to prosecute
Epstein for the conduct that occurred in
that district as for concerns that
prosecution on old allegations violate
the Double Jeopardy Clause of the US
Constitution the new indictment
apparently includes crimes which were
not charged in the older case including
Epstein bringing victims across state
lines there are also new factual
allegations against Epstein as well when
the government searched Epstein's new
york home they allegedly seized hundreds
of photographs of nude underage girls
the photos were kept on several CDs with
labels such as girl pics nude that's
something that's so on the nose you're
not even going to see that in an episode
of Law & Order SVU but that's what
happens when a criminal defendant things
that they are immune from prosecution
for the rest of their lives so what
happens next well there are a number of
unanswered questions the first of which
is what's going to happen to Jeffrey
Epstein in the new prosecution in the
Southern District of New York will the
courts allow the old plea deal to
provide any kind of immunity or will
they just simply throw it out
additionally we don't know what the
remedy for a violation the CVRA is does
that undo the plea agreement itself
meanwhile Acosta has argued that the
evidence wasn't particularly strong at
the time and that Miami prosecutors had
said that if the DOJ didn't get an
admission of guilt from Epstein that the
prosecutors were simply going to let
Epstein walk so having the DOJ get the
plea agreement that they did with jail
time was better than
nothing at all but one thing is for
certain Alex Acosta is now out of a job
after a press conference where he keeps
blame on victims and local Miami
prosecutors for the Epstein
non-prosecution agreement simply put the
Palm Beach State Attorney's Office was
ready to let Epstein walk free no jail
time nothing without the work of our
prosecutors Epstein would have gotten
away with just that state charge and and
as to a message the victims the messages
he need to come forward the writing was
on the wall and Acosta had to go Acosta
resigned and president Trump defended
him stating you know what I know about
Alex he was a great student at Harvard
he's Hispanic which I which I so admire
because maybe it was a little tougher
for him and maybe not but he did an
unbelievable job as the Secretary of
Labor that's what I know about him I
know one thing he did a great job and
until this came up there was never an
ounce of problem with this very good man
what today there is no witty remark or
pithy segue when I cover stories like
these it makes me want to do as much
good for as many people as possible
if this video leaves you wanting to do
some good in this world I'd recommend
tab for a cause which lets you raise
money for charity just by opening up
tabs and browsing the internet which you
were going to do anyway tab for a Cause
is a Google Chrome extension that allows
you to pick the charity of your choice
and then every time you open up a new
tab instead of there being a blank page
it displays a beautiful new customisable
tab with a couple of tiny ads the money
that you generate is then donated to
your charity the gorgeous new tab is
customizable and my favorite option is
that it shows you how much you are
generating for each specific charity
after you've opened up a tab or two you
can then choose the actual charity you
want the money to go to it's like a game
except you are actually changing the
world that you live in there's
absolutely no charge to you and it makes
a positive difference in this world
tap for a Cause users like you have
raised hundreds of thousands of dollars
for charity it is the easiest possible
way to donate to charity and make the
world a better place
so just click the link in the
description and download the extension
and do some good by doing what you were
going to do anyway do you agree with my
analysis did a cost to handle things
correctly or was he right to resign his
post leave your objections in the
comments and check out this link over
here with all of my other real law
reviews where I cover everything that is
going on in the world from a legal
perspective so click on the playlist and
I'll see you in court